we've got a musical guest the episode
isn't that long tonight cause i can't
talk
i can't [ __ ] speak
i just wanted to come in here and
celebrate uh
what was i what are we celebrating we're
celebrating uh uh well there's a lot to
celebrate i suppose like what uh it's
pride weekend this weekend oh it's pride
month it's a whole month yeah well
they're doing their pride parade this
weekend it's a it's a pride parade you
think rick russell will be at that
gay people love him they want their own
rich yeah they're all lying oh come on
oh yeah who cares
what the four fat lesbians on twitter
who write for
like no one respects who write for these
shows nobody watches on hulu and these
garbage shows on [ __ ] fox and [ __ ]
he's for fat non-binary people they
don't like him yeah but a lot of gay
people are rich and they want karussa
when they're putting homeless in a
frying pan
so i mean let's cut it out
you think gay people
left their homes in middle of america
you know where their parents hated them
they came here they got successful so
that they could step and piss and [ __ ]
this is you know what i mean this this
isn't they don't want that
but of course there's like some fat
unicorn on twitter
who's like you know it's just some fat
woman who's cross-eyed
tweeting about how rick caruso's like
you know
the [ __ ] you know
boston strangler
who's the one from london
oh the jack the ripper yeah she's like
jack the ripper and
gay people don't care so rick caruso go
down there in suits who just
put in hundreds and like twinks [ __ ]
g-strings
daddy caruso
you think rick caruso go down there and
full leather is like a leather daddy
that'd be great
if he's on a float
with billionaires you're all just
throwing money
he's dressed up like a leather daddy
and he's like i'm gonna make this city
safe
so you can get sucked off in a park
again
he gives a big speech
he's gonna this city used to be a place
where he could go get aids in a park
quietly
without worrying if some [ __ ]
schizophrenic was gonna throw his own
[ __ ] at you
unless you were into that
getting [ __ ] thrown at you used to be
something that was pre-arranged in this
city
now it's not
i want to make this city safe for random
strangers to suck each other's [ __ ]
without knowing each other's names
on benches again the way it used to be
i want to make this city safe
where women and children were horribly
abused by rich people
and thrown into the street to deal with
it
i want to make this city safe
for the people that made great art like
harvey weinstein
kevin spacey brett ratner and others
i want to make this city safe
you know
people like brian singer
would take you know 15 year olds and got
here from omaha
drugged them up and used them like
popsicles
[Laughter]
i want this city safe like he's doing
the speech
cause i want this city safe
because it's been taken over by fat
lesbians with no sense of humor
that's not what la's about
it's about [ __ ] with guns
people are clapping
there's a woman with a baby who's crying
he's like the movies we make are [ __ ]
now
the tv shows suck
he goes if you're anything like me you
got to watch a filipino maid got beat to
death on the dark web to come
nobody's clapping
he goes if you want to laugh now you
just have to watch old [ __ ] videos at
9 11.
he goes you can't even laugh unless
you're watching 9 11 videos if you're
anything like me people are going you
[ __ ] yeah wreck
this city's gone in a bad direction
he goes this is a city
of beautiful people that's been taken
over by ugly
untalented monsters
i want fat people out of here
i want fat people to feel the shame they
felt when i first moved here where a fat
woman would break down in tears after
what i would say to her at a grocery
store
i want that l.a back people are just
screaming caruso
caruso i want cruelty back
[Laughter]
i want evil back
i would vote for him if he did this
i bet i don't i don't even live here but
i'm saying
the reality is
that's what we need like an inspiring
speech about what la is
he's like la's a city about people that
move here to become something and in
order to do that they destroy everything
about themselves
and then they become something
completely different than the thing they
were
they reinvent themselves
and then at the end of their lives they
all get trapped in these big mansions
and they end up in pools
nobody understands what it's like to be
them
and they're just
[ __ ] paranoid demons
and then people want to be them and they
move here
they befriend these demons
that's what la is this a city about
freedom
he goes it's the greatest city in the
world
hella is such a great city
he just starts screaming his eye he goes
i want blood
i want blood again
people are like yeah this is beautiful
i mean maybe he'll go down there pride
pride week give real speech
he's like lesbians used to be in the
valley keep their mouths shut
this city is about closeted ceos getting
sucked off
by [ __ ] coked out rent boys he's
clamping
it's not about fat lesbian comedy riders
who look like [ __ ]
they look like [ __ ]
they have no sense of humor they're
gross they should be in new york
everyone's clapping
i don't care where you went to school
that's new york [ __ ]
we don't have school shootings our kids
are too stupid
they're all on only fans you can't
traffic our kids they traffic themselves
you rick
my son's a dj for christ's sake
[Applause]
but i mean you know we wish it well
he'll be fine
he'll be fine he's going to be okay
isn't it
isn't it going to be okay going to be
okay
you had francis ellis coming up here
barstool sports what did he do he hit a
woman that had with a brick or something
whatever they don't let him work anymore
he hit a woman in the head with a brick
i don't know what he did
he must have done something oh he made a
joke on a blog
about a woman who's dead
well
what are you gonna do rick russo laughed
rick caruso
you should have a you should have a
video
where a campaign ad where it's just some
models like sucking them off you just
see your head going up and down and he's
got a gun to her head like this
as he's going up and down and he goes
you know my favorite thing about la
because some people say it's the weather
because you know what i like about it
you just see her head bobbing up and
down he's got a gun right on her head
he's like you know what i really like
about la
he goes i liked it it goes it goes uh he
goes it's something that just gets in ya
you can't really explain what it is it's
just a certain magic that the city has
you know and her head is just
and he's like okay
get ready i'm close and he's just
jamming the gun in her head he goes i'm
close
i'm close
and it's like this ad was paid by for
rick caruso
um
he'll be fine
this city is going to be fun he'll solve
it all if he gets elected